we can tell that we're increasing the
number of patients that we're seeing on
a daily basis and we're getting fewer
callbacks so the nursing staff is being
much more helpful with seeing patients
that are in the office rather than
spending time on the phone but by and
large the patients come in they have
fewer questions we don't have the
callbacks much better educated on
exactly what's going to be done
surgically and for the non surgical
patients they have a much better
understanding of why we're having to
protect them why they're wearing a brace
why they're doing the rehab so overall
it's been a much better patient
education and from a physicians point of
view I think we're getting better
results because the patient's truly
understand what's going on
if you add from a surgical standpoint if
you add the amount of money that the
video calls per year versus the amount
of patients that you see because you
become more effective and more efficient
I would say the videos probably pay for
themselves after about two or three
patient
the end result is a beautiful animation
that's been viewed many millions of
times in seven languages so we really
are accomplishing our goal which is to
teach the world about this disease we're
reaching many people who have nothing to
do with our practice or just we're just
enhancing the education of patients and
doctors worldwide
enjoy all of my interactions with since
this medical they've been insightful
they've been very timely in their
efforts when we you know obviously
there's iterations and development of
these animations and every time that we
came back to them they were receptive to
our reviews and really sort of
intellectualize those comments and then
put them into action into making this
even better than we could've imagined